bonjour et merci de nous avoir rejoint
pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 dans
quelques instants avec que notre invité
Jean-Yves petit directeur du comité des
Yvelines de la prévention routière nous
allons parler notamment des nouveaux
radars embarqués qui seront mis en place
dès le 15 mars et puis vous aurez aussi
l'occasion dans cette émission de
découvrir un personnage étonnant et il
s'agit de Philippe Charlier les maîtres
de conférence en médecine légale et il
s'est occupé d'étudier le cœur le cœur
du roi Richard cœur de lion le plus
vieux coeur embaumé de France ça se sera
dans une quinzaine de minutes et puis
dans 30 minutes comme tous les lundis la
page de sport avec vous Anthony bonsoir
je recevrai Etienne ride et l'entraîneur
des seigneurs de Guyancourt ils sont à
l'heure actuelle en tête de leur pool de
promotion d'honneur mais ne gagne plus
en 2013 également sur ce plateau une
athlète de
spécialiste du 800 mètres cette saison
elle court pour récolter de l'argent
profit d'une association pour un sourire
d'enfants une association qui vient en
aide aux enfants du Cambodge et puis
comme d'habitude Catherine en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end voilà merci Antonio vous
retrouve donc dans une demi-heure mais
d'abord les titres les sujets qui seront
développés au cours de la prochaine
heure dans cette émission déjà une
semaine que la ligne SNCF entre la
verrière et la défense est interrompue
la reprise du service pourrait avoir
lieu le 14 mars et 50000 voyageurs
emprunt quotidiennement cette ligne les
locaux de la petite enfance à l'encours
ont déménagé un projet entamé il y a
trois ans le but centralisé les demandes
3000 familles sont reçus par ce service
et puis invaincu en tenue vous lisait
depuis le début de saison les féminines
du club de football d'Élancourt domine
outrageusement leur championnat de
promotion de luxe ce week-end elles ont
encore une fois de plus gagner leur
match en battant Colombes 3 à 0 et puis
à découvrir du côté de Magny-les-Hameaux
pendant la semaine de la femme de
l'aérobox un mélange de fitness et
d'arts martiaux mais donc que d'abord la
galère qui continue pour les usagers
privés de la ligne la verrière la
défense le trafic est interrompu depuis
une semaine et ne devrait pas reprendre
avant le 14 mars alors pourquoi une si
longue attente explication le 14 mars la
ligne SNCF entre la verrière et la
défense devrait reprendre du service la
ligne est totalement interrompue depuis
une semaine en cause l'incendie d'un
poste de signalisation à Sèvres
l'incendie a détruit l'ensemble de du
système de commande de dessiner des
signalisation sur la Ville d'Avray c'est
le système qui permet aux lignes
U et elle de d'accéder sur Saint-Cloud
le système de signalisation et de
commande il détecte l'arrivée des trains
il permet aussi de réguler la
circulation des trains une ligne eu
interrompue ce sont 50000 voyageurs
quotidiens qui doivent trouver des
itinéraires de délestage dès lundi une
centaine d'agents en gilet rouge était
mobilisé dans les gardes pour renseigner
des annonces sonores diffusées très
régulièrement
SNCF a aussi mis l'accent sur les
nouvelles technologies on a communiqué
au niveau du blog de la ligne nue et sur
Twitter également donc des nouvelles
technologies qui commencent à se
déployer de plus en plus pour
communiquer sur sur l'incendie qui a
lieu sur dans le poste de signalisation
de Sèvres et qui du coup un paquet la
circulation des trains et interrompu
complètement la circulation des trains
retour donc à la normale prévu dans une
dizaine de jours le système de
signalisation vieux de 20 ans sera
changé les agents de la SNCF s'activent
à tout remettre en route rapidement car
quand une ligne est au ralenti
l'entreprise doit verser des pénalités
au stifs le syndicat des transports
d'Île-de-France et elle pourrait
s'élever jusqu'à 3 millions d'euros
quant au voyageur pas de dédommagement
particulier ils ont reçu des coupons de
dépannage leur permettant de rejoindre
gratuitement Paris pour les
correspondances
et on va parler avec mon premier invité
des nouveaux outils mis au service de la
sécurité routière Jean-Yves petit
bonsoir vous êtes directeur du comité
des Yvelines de la prévention routière
et bien sûr on va d'abord parler des
fameux radars embarqués dont on parle
depuis quelques jours qui vont faire
leur entrée le 15 mars prochain
uniquement dans 18 départements les
Yvelines pour l'instant ne sont pas
concernés mais pour les automobilistes
qui nous écoutent les sols et Paris
l'Oise sont des départements assez
proches des Yvelines qui sont qui sont
concernés alors au total 300 véhicules
devraient être déployés d'ici trois ans
alors parlez-nous de ces radars
embarqués on ne les verra pas c'est les
radars invisibles c'est redoutable
ce sont des radars donc qui seront
embarqués dans les voitures des forces
de l'ordre police et gendarmerie voiture
banalisée bien sûr et les fonctionnaires
et les militaires seront en uniforme à
l'intérieur et c'est
radars flasheront flascheront il faut
pas dire ça parce qu'il y aura pas de
flash mais photographieront les voitures
contrepartie tu as autant de 31%
mais aujourd'hui nous ne parlerons pas
l'alcool nous parlerons
c'est intéressant effectivement de
rappeler quand même que la vitesse tue
encore beaucoup la vitesse tue beaucoup
trop malgré tous les radars qui sont
quand même installés en France il faut
quand même noter que ça a quand même ça
calme oui oui ça calme enfin pour
reprendre vos termes en 2002 vous vous
souvenez peut-être qu'il y avait 8000
tués par an sur nos routes et c'est
l'époque à laquelle le président Chirac
a fait de l'insécurité sur les routes
enfin la lutte contre l'insécurité
routière une grande cause nationale donc
2002 on avait 8000 tués sur les routes
2012 on en est pour la troisième année
consécutive à moins de 4000 donc on a
divisé par deux le nombre de tués sur
les routes et dans le même temps dans
ces dix années l'État a installé plus de
3000 radars sur les routes les gens en
tirent la conclusion qu'ils veulent moi
la mienne est faite
on a on a largement gagné sur la vitesse
alors vous avez pas le seul à être
convaincu un chantal Perrichon qui est
la président de la Ligue contre la
violence routière elle aussi est
largement convaincue puisqu'elle dit il
fallait une nouvelle technologie pour
que partout à tout moment les
automobilistes respectent les
limitations de vitesse l'association
victime et citoyens même chose ce nouvel
outil est la meilleure parade possible
contre le système d'avertisseur de radar
c'est la meilleure parade possible
puisque on peut pas les on peut pas les
détecter et puisqu'ils sont mobiles et
ils seront installés ou enfin ils patron
là où le préfet leur donnera en fonction
des des risques représentés par la
chaussée par la voix la voix de
circulation alors j'ai dit effectivement
il y a 18 départements qui sont
concernés pas les Yvelines dans un
premier temps mais ça veut dire qu'en
2013 ensemble de la France de tous les
départements français seront concernés
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure le
le l'État souhaite en installer 100 par
an pour arriver à 300 au 1er janvier
2016 est-ce que ces voitures banalisées
vont circuler plutôt sur des
départementales comme on le plutôt sur
des autoroutes est-ce que les zones les
plus dangereuses sont plutôt dans les
sur les départementales alors oui alors
il est vrai que les zones les plus
dangereuses c'est là où il y a le plus
de tuer c'est sur les départementales
mais il appartiendra à chaque préfet de
décider où ces voitures patrouilles et
les quatre les quatre types de voiries
sont concernés c'est-à-dire les
autoroutes les nationales les
départementales et les communes il y a
quand même malgré tout une voie un peu
dissonante qui se fait entendre c'est
celle de Pierre chazerey qui est
directeur de 40 millions
d'automobilistes et qui dit ça en fait
ça va ouvrir la voie toutes les
contestations parce que c'est pas un
radar
ultra précis comme peuvent être les
radars fixes et qu'en gros comme on
flashera pas on ne saura pas qui conduit
la voiture donc celui qui se rappelle
pénalisé forcément ses propriétaires de
la voiture c'est pas forcément lui le
conducteur alors tous les certainement
pas parfait va certainement y avoir des
contestations mais le fait que la marge
d'erreur soit passée à 10% au lieu de 5%
on va déjà quand même éliminer pas mal
de contestations et si on a la
conscience tranquille on a il y a pas de
problème si on double pas la voiture qui
roule à 130 km/h la voiture le
gendarmerie on n'a pas de souci
maintenant il est vrai que voiture
banalisée
tout à l'heure oui les agents de la
force publique eux seront eux ils seront
en uniforme
mais il y aura des contestations c'est
sûr mais bon
le but est de faire réduire la vitesse
au conducteur pour réduire le nombre de
tués sur les routes et comme vous l'avez
dit ça a été prouvé maintenant depuis
plus de 10 ans que c'est efficace alors
ça va augmenter le nombre de cas devant
les tribunaux
peut-être j'avoue que je ne sais pas
mais c'est bien possible oui c'est bien
possible
alors sur internet aujourd'hui j'ai eu
moi des certaines personnes annonçaient
le type de véhicule qui pourrait pas
patrouiller est-ce que quand on voit de
ce genre d'article sur des blogs ça vous
met en colère
vous dites c'est un peu irresponsable de
dire on va pas citer un outil de voiture
mais marque de voiture type de voiture
tout est il y a toujours les Robins des
bois ou les ou ceux qui sont qui sont
contre les tout ce qui est contre les
décisions prises par les forces de
l'ordre ou là ou la les règles édictées
par les forces de l'ordre mais bon ça
c'est je sais pas si c'est uniquement
français mais en tout cas c'est bien de
chez nous ça c'est sûr alors en tout cas
que pensez-vous des radars embarqués
c'est en tout cas la question que nous
sommes allés poser au 5 continents dans
la rue ce lundi on les écoute
le gouvernement va se faire un peu plus
d'argent tout simplement c'est important
pour la sécurité au tiers je trouve oui
une catastrophe aujourd'hui avec avec
l'éducation des radars de la répression
etc les gens ne vivent plus leur voiture
que comme quelque chose que comme
quelque chose d'outil terre pas comme
quelque chose de source de source de
d'évasion de rêves etc alors c'est vrai
qu'il y avait des excès mais d'un autre
côté là on est dans l'accès inverse ah
oui moi je trouve que c'est vraiment con
je suis vraiment con en train parce que
c'est vraiment des raquettes c'est bien
parce que c'est vite qu'il une question
par l'argent dans la mesure où les
autres avec un
coyote ou quelque chose qu'on peut se
payer on peut très bien savoir où ils
sont donc là au moins c'est pareil pour
tout le monde donc je trouve que c'est
bien de ce point de vue là
faut pas vous faire des illusions si ça
peut amener la sécurité c'est bien si
c'est pour ramasser des sous moi j'en
pense pas trop de bien je sais pas à
quoi ça va bien servir tout ça parce
qu'il y a déjà suffisamment de contrôle
sur les routes pour éviter disons
surtout les excès de vitesse bon
Jean-Yves petit alors là il y a quand
même de la communication à faire
par la moitié de de
vrai c'est une petite communication à
faire c'est pour ça que je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité une nouvelle fois
une personne dire c'est bien pour la
sécurité routière mais c'est tout
moi je je m'inssure je contre ça il y a
deux il y a deux enfin déjà le raquette
c'est c'est faux toute façon là en 2011
c'est radar ont rapporté environ 530
millions d'euros
qui vont qui ont été partis premier
tiers pour les radars eux-mêmes des
radars l'installation nouveau radar le
traitement les amendes deuxième tiers
aux collectivités locales pour la voirie
les départements les régions et
troisième tiers directement à l'état
pour des études sur les grands projets
d'infrastructures de voirie aussi c'est
pas du raquette il faut bien le faire ça
entretenir la voirie si ça se fait pas
avec les amandes des automobilistes ça
se fait de toute façon avec l'argent du
contribuable donc
il y en a aujourd'hui alors tout type
confondu un feu rouge mobile fixe etc on
est à on n'est pas loin de 4000 dans les
Yvelines dans les Yvelines il y en a une
55 et qui décide d'installation de ses
radars est-ce que c'est une commission
qui regroupe les forces de l'ordre le
préfet en fonction de zone plutôt
évidemment dangereuses c'est le préfet
qui décide
maintenant il s'appuie sur des
commissions en particulier des
commissions dans lesquelles les usagers
sont représentés je fais partie d'une de
ces commissions mais c'est bien le
préfet qui décide allez on va arrêter de
parler des radars
aussi d'une opération qui est lancée par
la prévention routière parce que c'était
ce weekend le premier départ premier
week-end de départ pour la zone C donc
c'est la zone qui nous concerne
directement et l'appréhension routière a
lancé une série de trois épisodes de sur
les bons réflexes sur sur l'autoroute
alors j'ai envie de dire pourquoi
l'autoroute parce qu'on a l'impression
quand on est sur l'autoroute on est
protégé
absolument nos autoroutes sont
particulièrement sûr c'est là où il y a
le moins de tuer le moins de blessés sur
toutes nos voies publiques
et nous avons effectivement enfin c'est
pas lancé mais poursuivi cette série les
bons réflexes sur l'autoroute puisqu'il
y a 12 12 conseils qui ont été donnés et
que vous que les vous avez été les
spectateurs peuvent retrouver sur le
notre site internet où la prévention
routière ou également par les sociétés
d'autoroute 107.7 enfin la radio donc
oui nous avons relancé pourquoi les
autoroutes parce que c'est sur les
autoroutes qu'on circule le plus dans
ces périodes de vacances en particulier
vers les stations de sports d'hiver pour
les gens de la zone C qui sont partis ou
qui partiront le week-end prochain alors
pour cette nouvelle série d'épisodes il
y en a 12 en tout il y en a trois la
nouvelle série il y avait il y a la
ceinture de sécurité alors aujourd'hui
enfin moi ça me paraît étonnant qu'on
soit obligé encore de dire mettez votre
ceinture de sécurité les gens sont assez
oui les gens sont toujours étonnés
alors
sur autoroute je pense pas qu'il y a de
problème de ceinture de sécurité sur
Auto tout le monde sait qu'il faut la
mettre mais la le nom port de la
ceinture de sécurité reste un facteur
très important en accident c'est la
troisième cause d'accident mortel mais
c'est surtout pour les enfants et
surtout à l'arrière les enfants qui sont
pas attaché pour les trajets très courts
sur l'autoroute pour les vacances je
pense pas qu'il y a de problème enfin
j'espère qu'il y aura pas de problème dû
à la ceinture de sécurité capital
important d'attacher sa century aussi
important d'adapter sa vitesse et
notamment quand on croise un chantier
parce que c'est souvent quelque chose
dont on ne parle pas c'est la sécurité
des agents sur la route exactement s'il
y a des limitations de vitesse
provisoires comme tout le monde le sait
à l'approche des chantiers c'est pour de
bonnes raisons c'est qu'il y a des gens
qui travaillent sur le bord de la route
et qui ont envie de rentrer chez eux le
soir il y a eu quand même quelques
accidents quelques accidents pardon
l'année dernière dont un accident mortel
dans le pays de l'autoroute qui se fait
renverser et tuer et une dernière chose
et là je trouve c'est très important le
bon usage des voix c'est l'usage du
clignotant qu'on oublie trop souvent
moi-même je l'oublie aussi donc on
l'oublie trop souvent ce clignotant un
jour merci de me donner l'occasion d'en
parler parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je ne comprends pas vous
devriez avec les micro-trottoirs
interroger vos interroger les gens
pourquoi pourquoi les gens ne mettent
pas leurs clignotants ça coûte pas cher
ça fait pas consommer l'essence c'est
pas fatigant et c'est utile des
conducteurs oublient leurs clignotants
dans un dépassement ce qui est énorme
incroyable et si vous permettez sur
l'autoroute je voudrais juste rappeler
que Conforama au code de la route on
tient sa droite donc on roule sur la
voie la plus à droite possible et en
double par la gauche bien évidemment ce
qui veut dire que je moi je je rouspète
contre les automobilistes qui roulent
pas très rapidement et qui reste sur la
voie du milieu ces gens là doivent
rouler à droite alors on roule à droite
et on met son clignotant on attache sa
ceinture et comme ça on a un trajet plus
tranquillisé sur l'autoroute on a vu
quelques quelques images de la vidéo qui
est visible sur le site de la prévention
routière un dernier mot Jean-Yves petit
qui n'a rien à voir avec la sécurité
routière la prévention routière mais
malgré tout pour informer une
téléspectateurs vous avez déménagé mais
rien ne change exactement
nous avons nous avons quitté nos bureaux
à Versailles pour emménager dans
d'autres bureaux à Viroflay
deux pas de la gare RER C de Chaville
Vélizy mais comme vous le dites ni notre
numéro de téléphone ni notre site
internet ni notre adresse internet ne
change merci d'être venu sur le plateau
de Téléfilm et je rappelle donc à partir
du 15 mars le déploiement des nouveaux
radars embarqués dans 18 départements
dont tout autour de nous les seules et
Paris allez on va quitter le monde des
adultes pour passer à celui de la petite
enfance à Élancourt le choix a été fait
de regrouper plusieurs services de la
petite enfance Valérie Auribeau nous en
explique tout l'intérêt et puis après on
parlera de cœur de Richard cœur de lion
la petite enfance déménage le 19 février
dernier les employés du service posaient
leurs cartons dans leur nouveau locaux
face à la mairie un projet envisagé
trois ans plus tôt nous avons estimé
qu'effectivement pour pouvoir recevoir
les administrés dans le meilleures
conditions que ce soit en termes de
qualité d'accueil mais aussi de
confidentialité il était nécessaire
effectivement de redéployer d'installer
le service sur une autre structure des
anciens locaux ou Nadar trop exigu mais
aussi une volonté de centraliser les
différents services de la ville pour
faciliter les démarches administratives
le service de la petite enfance
accueille chaque année près de 300
familles le service petite enfance
accueille les parents qui souhaitent
effectivement faire une pré-inscription
dans le cas d'une demande de place en
crèche et les prescriptions se font à
six mois de grossesse pour l'ensemble
des administrés elle reçoit ensuite les
parents au moment des renouvellements
les anciens locaux runadar sont
désormais exclusivement réservés à
l'accueil des assistantes maternelles